[Musique]
on
une
je sais juliette kamata je suis chef de
cuisine et pâtissières je suis installé
à joué-lès-tours et je propose des cours
de cuisine pour les particuliers et les
entreprises
soul enseignes de la cuisine autrement
j'ai choisi de transmettre mon métier
plutôt que de faire alors je vais vous
raconter un petit peu la recette qu'on
va réaliser c'est une banque une
tartelette aux poires parfumé au miel
d'acacia
on va avoir des petites noix qui sont
caramélisées et un sirop de jus de
raisin au poivre de kampot donc en fait
pour commencer la recette je vais faire
le sirop donc dans une casserole je
mettre le jus de raisin avec le poivre
et on va le porter mon cahier munitions
jusqu'à ce que sa atteignent la texture
d'un sirop ensuite on va préparer le
sablé breton
on va d'abord pour blanchir le jaune
d'oeuf avec le sucre et après on va
rajouter les autres ingrédients mêlant
je trouve ça comme si c'était une pâte à
tarte
on fait des petites boules qu'on étale
sur une
sur une plaque en mai ça au four pendant
que ça cuit on va mettre à égoutter
notre faisselle on va préparer les noirs
donc on va les hacher grossièrement donc
on le fait au couteau on ne fait pas
dans un appareil serait dans un appareil
ça fait plein de petits morceaux qui
vont griller après la pole qui vont être
trop cuites
on va faire torréfié noah à la poêle
donc on nous parle sur un départ à froid
on enlève les noix de la poêle on va
mettre notre sucre on va le faire
caraméliser
et on remet dedans
dans la poêle on remue très vite hors du
feu ensuite on va s'occuper de nos ports
dans une poêle à froid on va mettre un
petit peu de miel on va le faire un
petit peu chauffé on ajoutera apprennent
aux poires on va laisser le miel
caramélisées un petit peu et à la fin on
ajoutera un petit filet de citron qui
il a évité au pouvoir de s'oxyder on va
terminer notre note ficelle on a tout
simplement lui ajouter un petit peu de
miel d'acacia on va mélanger
après on va pouvoir passer au montage de
notre dessert du sirop de jus de raisin
pour le fond de la pâte sablée
vous disposez les points suivants et
donc on n'a plus qu'à déguster après
suit et black 2 et voilà
[Musique]